- [Voiceover] Amelia
started a puzzle at 12:56 pm
and solved it at 1:33 pm.
How long did it take
Amelia to solve the puzzle?
So we can see she started at 12:56 pm
and ended at 1:33 pm.
These are both pm and we'll
assume on the same day,
so that means it didn't take all the way
from morning to night.
They're both afternoon.
So she started at 12:56
and we want to know how long it takes
to get to 1:33 when she
finished the puzzle.
Well, from 12:56 to 1:00 pm,
we can figure out how long that is.
That's only four minutes,
there's only four minutes
between 12:56 and 1:00,
and then to get from 1:00
all the way to 1:33 pm,
is another 33 minutes, so Amelia worked
for four minutes, plus another 33 minutes
after one o'clock.
She worked for four minutes before 1:00,
33 minutes after one, so
she worked for a total
of 37 minutes on her
puzzle before solving it.